you have any videos or any pieces of
media or anything you've regretted
making online uh
uh yeah really plenty like what
um is there anything you wish you didn't
look into or anything you made that you
were like how should I make time like
looking back I wish I could have told
myself not to do it I wish I never did
that [__] L versus loose rap battle
why we would never met if we didn't do
that no because like that set you on a
path to be here today Joey on the trash
taste podcast I feel you and I would
have met some other fashion either way
you know because that Community was
already so small but like I look I
actually recently and like and by
recently I mean like within this year
actually watched that video again
um because you know why do you regret it
because I hit 10 years this year right
and I was just like I'm gonna you know
spend a day to just kind of look back
and reflect on where I've been to kind
of like you know do the 10-year video
which I did and I and I stumbled upon
the L versus Lush video and I was just
like holy [__] this is cringe like yeah
that's okay though but you use regret it
why do you regret it I I just like you
wish you didn't make it yeah I I you
know what I wish I wish I had made that
video better well yeah I always wish
that yeah is it like a con like is there
something you've made where you're like
I don't want any iteration of this to
exist I wish I didn't make it
it's hard because I've out of the three
of us I've definitely made the most
amount of videos yeah that's because you
did daily I did daily upload I have like
1200 videos I wish you didn't play
nekapore or something no I I don't again
I don't throw it out I don't regret
nicoparo or the Corpse Party era because
like yeah
how are you gone anything you regret
making or you all of it you feel like
yeah about yeah yeah I haven't I haven't
made that many videos
I have one video that I actually took
down just because of how painful it was
it was really early on in my career I
think I was like maybe a year or two
into this
um and I did a video where I was
absolutely shit-faced like I was like
seven or eight beers down right and I
decided my dumb ass drunk brain decided
hey it'd be a really good idea if you
filmed yourself right now and I did this
like three minute Vlog where I'm just
like in this app absolutely drunken mess
I didn't have my shirt on for some
reason so I was just like so it does so
there were Parts yeah so they were
passed in the video where I'm just like
zooming into my nipples and I'm just
like wait you got drunk
made this video and then edited it yeah
I like it I like while strong yeah I
remember vividly I I came back off I
came back from a full day of uni I
recorded like a bunch of like this video
about nothing it was just I think it was
just called I am drunk
just like me
like 7
7 after I've recorded like a couple of
episodes like nicoparo some RPG making
game or whatever I used to do and it was
just on my phone and I'm just like
recording this three minute [__] rant
about like me being drunk and I uploaded
it as a vlog on my main Channel with the
comments receptive uh I don't remember
to be honest I hope I didn't scar anyone
doing that but like I I took it down a
couple of years later I left it up there
because I completely forgotten about it
and then I think Aki was the one that
mentioned being like oh I love that
video where you're just like drunk as
[__] for three minutes
and then I was like what are you talking
about and then I looked back on my
channel those are the best videos yeah I
look back on the channel
I was just like I'm deleting
I've gotten to the point now where I've
been making so much stuff for so long
that you could show me video from six
years ago and I'll have no memory of
making it
um I
like cannot remember like half the
things I say on trash days it's like
becoming now I genuinely can't remember
anything well I don't remember what I
said I remember we used to we used to
watch we used to we used to all I'm
slouching like crazy don't don't worry
about it
I'm we used to watch all the episodes
we'd all go through them yeah and review
them and then we realized hold on this
is insane I can't watch me talk about
[__] that I talked about every week
[__] two hours so we stopped watching
what was the last episode you fully
watched all the way through
uh maybe the Pete one
oh yeah I mean that was a good video
that was a good episode I mean pizza's
so [__] I'm not I'm not okay not
including guest episodes oh like like
just us like two plus years yeah right
because I feel that like when we talk
it's like ingrained in my memory like I
don't need to watch it again I I
remember like because I'll also remember
stuff that I said that I'm like
and I'll be like was it as bad as I
remember it being they'd be like nah I'm
like okay good yeah because I I I have
that like every week I have that
enjoyment of like a news I don't know
what the [__] we talking and you trash
this episode goes up and I'm like I
don't remember the what the [__] I said
I skimmed through for like the first 30
minutes and I'm just like damn I'm about
to get [__] flame for this [__]
all right
have you out in a moment where you set a
take on trash taste and you're like
oh this is gonna like cause all the time
all the time
but also like I realized
I felt like enlightened when I stopped
when I would was willing to say those
takes and be like I don't care about the
aftermath yeah it felt like a power and
I kind of get it a little bit about
these like almost like how these scumbag
YouTubers stay around forever yeah
because they just don't care no yeah
like they see all these comments that
are negative and they just like you it's
so easy to to just get to that point
like I actually just don't care dude
yeah like thousands of people hate me
yeah and I don't give a [__] dude the
moment the moment I finally said on a
trash day episode that I Think Jesus
kaisen is made
okay okay
can I
can I I remember one time I was watching
a video that was Acky and she was like
she was talking about a Ghibli movie she
didn't like yeah and she blurred the
movie that she said that she didn't like
wait which one it was My Neighbor Totoro
because I asked her afterwards I was
like what what was the movie that she
didn't like and she bleeped what she
said because she was so afraid oh that
people would be so I remember that it
was so angry at her I remember saying
that she didn't like my my favorite
meanwhile said like multiple times yeah
like and then we look back at him like
how dumb were all of us to think that
you couldn't be like I don't like yeah
no I I okay considering that video I
specifically remember being like what
the [__] who the [__] is an opinion yeah
it's an opinion there's a lot of people
who don't like my avatar for multiple
reasons as a fan of my neighbor tutorial
and someone who grew up with it I don't
give a [__] like if you don't like it
that's completely understandable
everybody's still up it must be still up
of her believing it probably it's a very
old video yeah okay I should remember
this conversation with that kid I was
like I don't
that was that was during the period
where it was like we didn't know the I
guess the boundaries upon which you
could yeah exactly yeah exactly like
popular media I mean like okay so like I
think there's some merits like worrying
about that like I'm I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be real yeah as someone who's
talked about like anime for like [__]
10 plus years have you
oh God yeah like okay so negativity on
the like on the online space especially
when it comes like talking about media
you get like
you got like two three passes right
before people before like yeah I
actually agree with this genuinely
genuinely negative like if you talk
negative about something in terms of
like if you're like a big reviewer you
get two three passes both before people
are like this guy just changed
everything yeah they're right yeah they
just write you off right I think also in
a in like a small drama perspective as
well I've noticed that you can do two
little [__] ups but let me do too many
little [__] ups people are like I just
got a bad feeling about him yeah you
know what I mean and then you kind of
lose a lot of uh trust with people
concerning concerning the first part
when it comes to like giving opinions on
[__] that is not widely accepted that's
my [__] life well I mean in one video
saying that uh maybe someone online bad
and now I became a combini wine I
recognize it yeah it is this is the
cheap one yeah sort of online and it's
same with me for like I realized I was
like man people give a [__] about this
[__] when I yeah when I spoke about 86
being [__] boring yeah and
I I genuinely like uh one of the things
I've done or like how I've shifted my
channel like remember the [__]
Angry Video Game Nerd guy with the
glasses kind of days
yeah I mean like it was there was a
period of the internet where people
thought it was really really cool to
hate on [__] and then it suddenly just
became like uncool overnight because
people just got tired well it's weird
because the YouTube it is cool but
Twitter it's not uh sorry YouTube it
isn't cool and Twitter it is cool so
it's kind of it's whatever you want to
go I mean it's I feel like
I no it's cool on Twitter yeah
because like uh
uh I don't know it was like back in the
day when people just call out YouTubers
for whatever reason and now I feel like
YouTubers have gotten to the point where
we're trying to just make a [__] job
out of this we'll just survive yeah and
so the the when you like I want to call
that person why they're a piece of [__]
it's like okay but like
what's that gonna do like yeah you look
like the [__] yeah yeah
and so it's like even if there are
scumbag YouTubers out there I think a
lot of people aren't [__] pushing or
trying to expose people anymore because
it's like it's kind of like not much
benefit to doing it because everyone
just trying to make a business it's like
you know I'm sure it's like [__] way
back in the day when you sabotage your
[__] competitor and pizza making and
you're like actually just works out
better if everyone just likes Pizza more
uh let's just not [__] each other over
sure yeah I mean like it's it's kind of
like people just get tired like of
someone who's just really negative and
that's why I realized oh that's pungent
oh I'm sorry this is combini wine now
yes I've got a last Good carry on Karen
yeah so like I remember like I I made
like a conscious decision with my
content yeah to like shift it to you too
yeah to like Okay so
I I know I've gotten like a lot of
comments being like Oh God likes
everything God never shits on a show and
I'm just like I there are shows that are
popular that I don't like I just choose
not to like highlight them what do you
get out of shooting on a show yeah yeah
exactly you lose a bit of your audience
yeah you know you know
the problem is that video was is gonna
blow up because a lot of people are
going to be like yo he hates someone
show he dunks on a show and you get like
you should make a one-piece video
shooting on the one piece fans I'll
Crush
you basically just described my entire
career until a couple of years ago yeah
because here's here's the thing you get
like two or three and like people are
with you and then I've noticed after
like a few too many shows that you hate
on even if you're like genuinely like
have points they'll be like this is just
a negative person yeah I don't wanna I
think I think for the majority of people
who like kind of know me on a surface
level I'm just known as the guy who's
like he hates sword online he thinks
school days is 10 out of 10. he did make
a lot of video [__] on it no I made
one did you really I literally I in my
head I thought that you made some videos
this is the thing so many people think I
am like the I hate someone like I made
one video and it was a parody of like my
character Vegeta review 69 yeah if you
remember you're an OG of like him like
making this like satirical parody on
saying like it's the best anime ever
even though I'm shooting on it and that
one video has like labeled me as like
he's the guy that hates soil line I'm
like wait wait okay but first of all
I've never heard anyone say this about
you no dude so many people say that
about me I think it's a case of like you
see it the most because you're the guy
because I don't see this man I've never
seen this appear I don't know but like
I've seen this opinion yeah oh okay yeah
a lot I'm not trying to Gaslight you no
no I get it like a lot of people I want
to be the guy that hates oceanoco it's
cringe
the moment I say like in one video I'm
like yeah I think uh school days was
kind of brilliant
immediately I'm the guy that's like oh
he thinks school days is 10 out of 10
and everyone knows it's a [__] anime so
his opinions are invalid because he
doesn't watch anime anymore and it's
just and I'm just like okay yeah sure
like take away all of my opinions from
the past like 10 plus years of like
watching anime
yeah I mean I mean that's it's it's like
I constantly have to bot
a bottle uh because you have to battle
between you know stuff that let's say I
watch a show and I don't like it I can't
have to battle between like how much do
I highlight to show that I was not a fan
of versus like I've taken like the
content I never noticed you had been
positive throughout your videos but now
it makes a lot of sense yeah I mean like
I'm not POS like that doesn't mean God
doesn't in a smile yeah that doesn't
mean I hide that doesn't mean I like
everything but you don't [__] on it no
no no no no like here's the thing here's
the thing exception's dog whatever yes I
I just highlight the stuff that I like
you know I don't like I don't [__] on
the stuff that I don't like like it's
not that I'm afraid of [__] on it I
just want more like it's it's like it's
like a kind of like a shift to be like I
just want more coverage on the stuff
that I do like that makes sense rather
than just covering
yeah yeah you you did it in a smart way
where like you decided to not go against
the north to go against the norm rather
and just cover stuff that you are
actually passionate about you actually
enjoyed whereas during that same period
in the like mid to late 2010s uh
especially in the attitude Community it
was like almost a trend to be like hey
let's oh that was a trend on YouTube
yeah right like let's watch your movies
and dissect on why it [__] sucks and
you know I admit I I'm fully I was fully
involved in that movement and you know
in a lot of respects I got big because
of that I mean it's easier to
and you know there's I mean you can look
at this from the the game reviewers you
know because some game reviews do top 10
games a year top 10 worst games of the
year you'd always see the worst games of
the year one would do so much better of
course it does makes people just love
negativity negative like here's the
thing like I don't want to hear someone
tell me about what the best game was I
know what the best game yeah exactly I
mean like it's like negative minions is
like the easy way to get views yeah
which is why I always just like not that
I was like I'm against easy views I'm
just like I just want to focus on the
things that I do [__] like because my
life is happier if I do so I'm like like
here's a big tell about if I don't like
something or if I don't like a show I
just don't talk about it like that
that's like the biggest deal see I just
don't talk about it this man this man
built it